Joe Biden is on this show with the radio
character Charlamagne tha God and the
interview is actually going fairly well
and then Joe Biden made this now
infamous statement that if you do not
know if you're gonna vote for Trump or
for Joe Biden then you ain't black
I joined if you have a problem figuring
out whether you're from mere Trump and
you ain't black so listen to what he's
saying it what he's saying is actually a
little bit more radical even than what
some people are suggesting he's not
saying that if you're a Republican and
you're black then you ain't black he's
not saying that if you're not gonna vote
for me then you ain't black it's
actually even further than that what
he's saying is if you even have the
slightest question as to whether or not
you're gonna vote for me if it if it
even enters into your mind that it would
be possible to vote for a Republican
then you ain't black in order to be
authentically black according to Joe
Biden you have to be unconsciously
democratic unconsciously left-wing
obviously that is absurd the the
craziest image of all the most absurd
image of all is that Joe Biden one of
the whitest people that has ever walked
the face of the earth is now telling
someone like Kanye West that he is not
black telling someone like Tim Scott
that he is not black telling someone
like Allen West that he's now black
right the list goes on and on the left
immediately started making excuses for
him close your eyes imagine what the
headlines would look like if a
Republican had made a similar statement
could you imagine right it would be
wall-to-wall coverage outrageous he has
to resign this guess is like David Duke
is running for president right that's so
that's what you were deferred but
because it was Joe Biden because it was
a Democrat here the headline CNN what
Biden said was outrageous but some say
so was the reaction some say that a who
is some is some is some the nickname of
Blake CNN writer it's that that seems to
me very likely or not even John Blake
the writer but whoever the editor is
that wrote that headline this is
something that the left always does when
they get a bad series of headlines and
they want to counter that narrative they
say okay here's the headline yeah that's
really bad but some say it's not that
bad and then the some who say it are
always just the left-wing journalists
who are writing writing the headlines
so that's CNN you get from Vox do Joe
Biden's you ain't black comments
ultimately matter no no of course not
if Joe were a Republican they would
matter a whole lot but now do they
matter no that now this is the Clinton
strategy the Vox the Vox headline is
what you would always see from the
Clintons which is that the Clintons
would have some scandal and then they
would just immediately tamp it down say
this is old news we mean it's old news
this scandal happened yesterday now it's
old news it happened yesterday today's
today it's not a big deal move on the
organization move on org people very
prominent left-wing organization was
founded to to get the Clintons through
the impeachment and they said well look
we got to move on this is old news no
big deal
doesn't matter nothing to see here folks
that's what vox.com did and then my
favorite one came from the most
ridiculous of all of those newspapers
The Washington Post democracy dies in
darkness
this headline on an article by Jonathan
Capehart
come on Biden's you ain't black comment
was clearly a joke what was the joke I
saw some people in social media tried to
say this that Joe Biden was joking and
so therefore it's not an offensive
comment what's the joke all right look
I'm I'm perfectly willing to give people
grace if they're telling jokes what is
the joke that black people have to vote
for Democrats is that I guess that's the
that's what he's saying
the joke is black people can't think for
themselves the joke is black people need
to vote the way that this white man
tells them to vote that
haha isn't that the joke huh look it's
clear yeah yeah I know I if that's the
joke
I get the joke but that's what is
offensive so it's not a joke I mean a
joke requires a setup and a punch line a
joke requires some humor that's not what
Joe Biden was saying Joe Biden's point
was was pretty blunt which is that if
you are black you must vote for
Democrats and if you don't vote for a
Democrat you lose your blackness that
then this is the kind of ideological
point that they come to somehow there is
a difference between being racially
black and being politically black and
the one that actually matters more is
whether you're politically black
regardless of your skin color this is
the precise point that was made by a New
York Times writer not just any New York
Times writer a woman who just won the
Pulitzer Prize for that
16:19 project that completely anti
historical trash that the New York Times
is using to try to rewrite American
history this woman's name is Hannah
Jones and she said basically just what I
just said she said quote there is a
difference between being politically
black and being racially black I am NOT
defending anyone but we all know this
and should stop pretending that we don't
so she is defending him and it is a
repulsive comment what she's saying this
is what ideologies do this you know I
tried I tried not to be too ideological
on the show I have a point of view I
have a vision of the world but I try not
to be ideological and the difference is
this what idiot logs do is they
prioritize their ideas over reality so
when reality comes to contradict their
ideas they they don't deny their ideas
they deny the reality this is something
you would hear as a kind of joke about
ideologue they'll say who cares if it
works in practice doesn't work in theory
right it's all about prioritizing ideas
of a reality when the two conflict they
go with their own theories and this is
where we see identity politics really
delve into the realm of the
surd the idea here is that if you are
say tim scott right a republican black
senator you are not really black if
you're Clarence Thomas right you're a
conservative black jurist you're not
really black I mean sure your skin is
black but blackness is something deeper
than skin color it is according to the
left a political ideology and so so Bill
Clinton right very much a white guy is
the first black president in certain
colloquial understandings Sarah Palin is
not a woman I once read kid you not I
read a Gender Studies paper a published
academic Gender Studies paper that
denied that Sarah Palin is a woman
because of her ideology because her
ideology is conservative or her I guess
her philosophy is conservative or her
lack of ideologies her ideology right
Rick Ranaut he's the acting DNI he's a
homosexual but he's not really a
homosexual you see according to the left
he can't possibly really be a homosexual
because he is more conservative he's not
a leftist for the let for the left black
is not a race it is an ideology one
woman is not a sex it's an ideology gay
is not a sexual preference it is an
ideology so leftist men can attack
Phyllis Schlafly
right they can attack an Coulter that's
fine it's actually feminist to
physically attack those women because
they're not really women and if you
attack them then you're actually the
real feminist and Kanye isn't really
black according to this ridiculous idea
[Music]
you
[Music]